how did you become obsessed with cheese
we were just talking about how we have
like Americanized diets so I'm born and
raised here in Los Angeles from
immigrant parents from Korea and so I
grew up on a lot of rice but because I
was also American I also grew up on a
lot of craft singles so I would
literally open the rice cooker unwrap
the cheese and put it on top of the rice
and then close the cooker even today A
lot of times my breakfast is just like a
flamed tortilla with a string cheese
rolled up inside even though I own the
store full of cheese I eat a lot of
string cheese really yeah it's good to
know that all cheese is still acceptable
oh yeah absolutely I mean I feel like it
gets very intimidating to look into this
case and see oh I've never seen all of
these things before what are these
flowers what is this mold but just to
let people know that it's just cheese
and it could be accessible to everybody